this morning on the dish
arizona-born indigenous chef brian
yazzie he comes from the navajo nation
where he learned ancient food traditions
from his family
now he's brought them to minnesota using
local ingredients to create modern
dishes while
caring for his community in a particular
time of need
jamie yukis has his story this is
dehydrated prairie sage the ingredients
techniques and presentation are all
rooted in tradition
you almost made like a squash dip yeah
pretty much
did your mom make indigenous food
growing up i remember my mom
stepping out the back door getting some
lambs quarters known as wild spinach she
would pull down to the potato super
mutton
monster you know just a little taste of
the landscape that was my
introduction to native food indigenous
food is known for three
key ingredients called the three sisters
it's corn bean squash
they definitely help each other grow in
the garden and they also complement each
other you know
on the table as well so but corn is one
of the main staples with with my tribe
and here in the midwest there's one
sister that we add called the fourth
sister and that is wild rice
brian yazzie started cooking for his
family a big family
when he was just seven years old being
the youngest out of eight sibling
and coming from a single pound household
i tried
my best growing up to help my mom when
he wasn't behind the stove
yazzie got involved with the wrong crowd
in arizona i started following the
negativity in the environment
gang activity stealing car stereos so i
did not receive my high school diploma
until
i was at the age of 25. then one day
while out on the streets
came a call from his sister that led him
to his passion
she was saying we missed her cooking why
don't you come home and
prepare a meal for the week i would come
home for days at a time to cook
and that was their way of checking on me
you know so i came off the term that
cook can save my life
but it wasn't until his now wife huna
mana gave him an
ultimatum moved to minnesota together
for a fresh start
or she was leaving him that's when he
knew he needed to choose a new path
and when they received the brochure in
the mail from saint paul college
and i see all the shiny appliances you
know the fruits the bed the flames so
that hooked me
now his goal is to inspire the next
generation of young chefs
my philosophy is cooking into worlds
ancestral knowledge with modern
techniques traveling around the world
sharing his knowledge and picking up
local native ingredients
used in dishes he prepares at the
gathering cafe it's almost like a meal
now
like this hot chocolate yazzie's
assistant vanessa casillas stirred up
for us
i cannot wait to try this yeah cheers
oh my gosh it smells wonderful so this
is the soup
yeah this one is red chili pizzoli and
it has a roasted duck
and the corn is a traditional corn to
the navajo tribe
what's a little bit of spice in here um
it would be red chili new mexican
red chili minnesotans in general are not
known for
liking spicy or anything no no too crazy
no i had to balance out you know um i
started with ketchup
no i'm kidding no it had to bounce out
more mild
more um you know more of a smoky flavor
what i tasted earlier that had the spice
in at the pizzool
yeah would you normally have that like
two times as hot 10 times as hot
probably five times it's hot yeah really
yeah yeah i try not to do too much when
i'm cooking
regardless of manipulating one
ingredient i try and keep it with his
original flavor profile
no especially with the owlers i try and
reintroduce these type of ingredients
that i've been forgotten about
reintroducing these type of natural food
products
is kind of it's more of a struggle when
the pandemic hit the cafe was forced to
close
and his team went from serving a hundred
meals a week in its dining room
to cooking and delivering meals to
native elders every day for
free grants local health care companies
and jose andreas charity world central
kitchen
are helping fund the meals i think a lot
of us who pay attention to news
headlines have been just so
concerned about the navajo nation when
it comes to the pandemic and how hard
it's been hit
here in twin cities it's the top five
urban native community
in north america majority of the elders
are the last people holding on to the
languages and the cultures so that was
my way of
giving back to the community if the
elders die and the language dies
yeah what do you have anymore culturally
yeah i mean the same thing with food
right
has it been interesting to you that it's
become almost a fad to have indigenous
food or people wanting to hear more from
indigenous
chefs yeah i mean i think the time is
now five years ago you wouldn't have
heard about this
probably heard about indian taco as a
fry bread and so now you have people
talking about heirloom squash
different type of amaranth or quinoa we
have always been here you know we're now
we're just circling back to
reclaiming our spaces in the kitchen and
how lucky for all of us who get to
experience the culture
and learn about the past through yazi's
cooking
for cbs this morning saturday jamie
yukas minneapolis
i miss us tasting
[Music]
i know and the colors of it all just
using all of those things from the past
and sort of reintroducing them in
different ways like that traditional and
the modern
is one of my favorite things to see with
chefs how great did that hot chocolate
look
right this morning we're hungry